حسنًا ، إنه تاريخي تمامًا لأنه أه
في الماضي
العربي وخاصة العالم العربي السني
وهذا جانب رئيسي
من هذا إذا لم يتم إعلان
الدولة اليهودية عدوًا باستثناء
الأردن ومصر بالطبع كلاهما كان بالطبع
تم إغلاق الأبواق حرفيا
مع إسرائيل في الماضي ولكن لديها اتفاقات سلام ،
جعلت بقية العالم العربي
أي نوع من تطبيع
العلاقات مع الفلسطينيين
أمرًا بالغ الأهمية
للاتفاق الإسرائيلي على إقامة
دولة فلسطينية مستقلة قابلة للحياة
تعيش في سلام
جنبًا إلى جنب مع  إسرائيل الآن التي
كانت هي مبدأ اتفاقيات أوسلو
كانت أيضًا قبل كل شيء مبدأ
الاقتراح العربي الذي وضعته
أو أعدته المملكة العربية السعودية بشكل أساسي
الآن
أه منذ أكثر من عقد ونصف
والذي كان أساسًا فعليًا
للموقف الرسمي للدولة  العالم العربي
ولكن ما يحدث في هذه الأثناء
هو أنه على أي حال بالنسبة للعديد من ممالك الخليج
في العالم العربي ، فإن
فلسطين  لقد كانت
قضية خارجية مفيدة أه
لإبراز الاهتمام بما قد
يحدث داخليًا
خارجيًا إذا كنت تحب أن يكون
الدعم الفلسطيني للقضية الفلسطينية
خطابيًا غير حقيقي والآن
هناك أجيال جديدة من القادة
أه خاصة القادة الغربيين المثقفين
أناس متطورون في الدولة  الشرق الأوسط
واه في دول الخليج ، من
وجهة نظرهم ، يرون ميزة أكبر
في علاقة إستراتيجية أوثق بكثير
مع كل من الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل
عندما يتعلق الأمر بإيران وإيران هي
التي يرون
أنها أكبر تهديد منفرد وفي
نفس الوقت مع ذلك  إنهم يرون أن
القيادة الفلسطينية
لا تختلف عن العديد من الفلسطينيين أنفسهم على
أنها شيخوخة فاسدة عاجزة
تفتقر تمامًا إلى الأفكار وحتى
أي نوع من الطاقة القيادية
يهرول ببساطة على
الاعتراضات القياسية على المناورات التي يقوم
بها الإسرائيليون الآن
لم يكن للشارع الفلسطيني أي صوت
في بناء  هذه الصفقة ولا
فيما يسمى بصفقة السنتور
ويبقى أن نرى
إلى أي
مدى سيرحب الشارع العربي على نطاق واسع
بالتطبيع
مع إسرائيل أو لا يبالي به أو
يتفاعل معه بطريقة قد تكون عنيفة
وبالطبع في
خضم كل هذا من المرجح أن يكسب
في الاستراتيجية الاستراتيجية.
من المحتمل أن تكون إيران لأن
الإيرانيين من خلال
مذهبهم في المقاومة
هم الذين دافعوا عن القضية الفلسطينية
على الرغم من أنهم بلد محض ،
والفلسطينيون
هم في الغالب من المسلمين السنة ولكنهم
مؤثرون بالفعل
في قطاع غزة